el terremoto más mortífero en una de
cada uno de magnitud 6 1 que dejó casas
reducidas a escombros por doquier al
menos un millar de muertos y una cifra
de heridos que aumenta con el paso de
las horas según el servicio geológico de
eeuu el sismo se registró en paktika una
remota provincia al sureste de
afganistán pero que también cobró la
vida de cientos de personas de al menos
otras seis provincias y la sacudidas
llegó hasta los países vecinos pakistán
e india las autoridades locales
dispusieron de varios helicópteros para
llevar suministros médicos y transportar
a los heridos
con base a las órdenes del primer
ministro se ha decidido que se
entregarán en mil 116 dólares en
efectivo a las familias de las víctimas
y 558 dólares en efectivo a las familias
con heridos como ayuda urgente
jones eric gull
afganistán es un país que vive de forma
constante las consecuencias de los
fuertes sismos en la última década más
de 7000 personas han fallecido a causa
de los terremotos una cifra que se
traduce a 650 decesos en promedio al año
la mayoría de casas de las personas
afectadas están hechas de barro o
estructuras de ladrillo una situación
que deja a los habitantes en una mayor
condición de vulnerabilidad y que
preocupa a varias organizaciones
humanitarias
desde la era medianoche cuando se
produjo el terremoto los niños y yo
gritamos una de nuestras habitaciones
quedó destruida nuestros vecinos
gritaron y vimos las habitaciones de
todos normal aquella vez el desastre
podría significar un reto mayor para los
talibanes quienes han tenido que
gobernar sin la ayuda financiera de la
comunidad internacional desde que
tomaron el poder el pasado agosto de